if you can't learn to run with the pack  one of these days you'll be someone's  dinner  akan help but notice there's the strange  odor today man is forbidden  the jungle is no longer safe for you  only man can protect you now  poor sweet little cow what are you doing  so deep in the jungle you are a man-cub  who wants to live in a jungle how you  know that kid I got is my ears got is  only I can protect you  forget about your losing Australian snap  that's a song about the good life  he will stop at nothing to be has this  boy if anything happens to that kid I'll  never forgive myself  come on move let's be on our way but I'm  helping blue get ready for hibernation  bears don't hibernate in a jungle not  full hibernation but i nap a lot all  masseuses clan is mansion kids